I think Biden as inefficient and as weak
as he's proven to be would still beat
Trump in 2024. you really think that
well he already did it he already did it
and there's a chance he could do it
that's how tarnish trumps
look at the polls guys
last Point DeSantis would wipe out bite
him okay I love how everybody's laughing
I love how everybody's laughing I said
this exact same thing about 2020. you're
crazy you're crazy I'll tell you what's
different there's a difference
here's what's different okay so you know
the whole uh uh fraud election whatever
whatever they talk I'm not even talking
about ballots I'm not talking about the
2000 mules I'm not talking any of that
stuff set that stuff aside you believe
it happened you didn't believe it
happened it is what it is that's been
happening for a long time you guys got
to get it better at catching these
things happening I'm not even going
there uh Hunter Biden's story
if that story State he ain't getting
reelected when James Comey came out with
the story about Hillary Clinton a week
before election Hillary lost believe it
or not as much as James Comey as Hillary
Clinton's best friend he caused her to
lose he could have waited a one and a
half week more Trump ain't winning
Tom and I are on the phone at 3 30 in
the morning were shell shocked when they
announced Trump one and Hillary Clinton
had to call and concede we're like
are you awake is this a like what the
hell is going on that was James Comey
okay because it was a week out that New
York uh post story was a week out fast
forward to today the amount of content
this is the part about being the
president you give your enemies a lot of
content okay your enemies you don't have
any content on your enemies because he's
been on the bench Trump's not been
active he's been on the bench for the
last four years right Biden's been on
the bench Trump has 15 different things
he can bring up about Biden
my concern he goes against Biden he
beats Biden I don't think I think that
the Santa's part is a concern if the
left picks somebody else
if it's a Michelle if it's someone else
it's a different story but I think
Biden's resume is not sitting pretty
he's gonna okay you ready all right 83
billion dollars Afghanistan okay uh what
do you call it Hunter byton laptop you
got uh Ukraine world war three first
time since 1970 that Russia has put you
know nuclear weapons on their ships do
you want me to keep going what happens
with China and Iran and Russia unifying
becoming a new world order in the other
side that the New World Order you made
the three enemies of America become
United what the hell are you doing what
kind of diplomacy is that he he is
destroyed in that area so Trump's going
to play to that card no problem I think
Democrats truly have to figure out a way
to get Biden to step aside and bring
somebody else in they need somebody else
I don't think Biden is going to win
against him so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]